ah
Final Fantasy 15 has been in development
for nearly a decade and as a result has
undergone a multitude of changes but
among these changes what has transformed
the most is the combat system first
available to us in Episode two skaia
combat has changed in a myriad of ways
throughout the various builds here are
all the major ways comet has evolved
episode Disgaea gave us her first taste
of Final Fantasy 15s combat offering a
glimpse at noctis's multi-blade fighting
style this early iteration focused on
equipping weapons to particular
instances of a combo for example you
could assign a spear to the opening blow
of noctis's combo and then assign a
sword to the flurry of attacks that
followed depending on the weapons you
assigned to those particular instances
you could change noctis's fighting style
in interesting ways
while this combat system was subtly
altered with minor balance adjustments
via the episode - sky a 2.0 patch it was
completely overhauled in the Platinum
demo in that build noctis brandished
multiple weapons each with their own
particular set of attacks and animations
and he could manually switch between
them mid combo the combat system in this
build is the same as the final preview
build of the game such as switching the
lock-on button and altering the
armatures attack animations
weapons functions similarly across all
builds with each type retaining its
overall feel and attack animations
however slight alterations were made as
the builds went on episode disguise 2.0
patch added the ability to perform
variations to a weapons attacks
depending on the direction you were
holding for example if you held forward
you can perform lunge attacks with your
sword
the final preview build implements these
changes while adding in enemy
resistances which makes enemies
invulnerable against certain weapon
types but weak against others however a
major feature that didn't make it to the
later builds was the techniques from
episode Disgaea which were powerful
special attacks tied to weapons in your
arsenal that consumed MP
magic wasn't implemented in episode
Disgaea but we did see it in the
Platinum demo where it was showcased as
limited items you could equip and cast
against enemies while this has been
retained in the final preview build
Magic has been made more complex thanks
to the spell crafting system which
allows it to be given special effects
depending on the items you combine it
with in the crafting process for example
you can craft a lightning spell with a
curse status effect that diminishes
enemy attack power in each file fantasy
15 build mana points are tied directly
to noctis's warp blade abilities and
evasive maneuvers in episode Disgaea
evasive maneuvers techniques and
armature consumed MP however when the
2.0 patch was released the game was
updated to exclude guarding right before
an enemy attack from consuming MP these
changes were mostly retained in both the
Platinum demo and the final preview bill
with the exception of Armiger which was
given its own separate meter using too
much MP renders and Octus into a
weakened state called stasis the only
way to recover from this is by taking
cover or warping to a safe space this
constraint has been kept consistent
across all builds though small changes
have been made to balance it initially
in episode Disgaea you could attack in
stasis and you even recovered MP 4 in an
unlimited amount of time when hanging on
to a point orb however you can no longer
do either in both the Platinum demo and
the final preview build
in the initial version of episode
Disgaea you could only defend yourself
by getting it to a stance that allowed
you to face through oncoming enemy
attacks at the cost of MP a much
requested dodge roll was later added in
the 2.0 patch while slight adjustments
were made to how much MP was consumed
when phasing through attacks in the
defensive stance
as you fight enemies in battle your
attacks inevitably stagger them in
episode Ischia this weakened state was
referred to as off-guard however it has
been renamed to vulnerable in the final
preview build a backstab mechanic called
blind site has also been added to the
final preview build this gives you the
ability to deal more damage to enemies
when you hit them from the rear when
episode Disgaea first launched noctis's
party would only support him with
standard attacks however once the 2.0
update rolled around you could perform
cross chains special cooperative attacks
that could only be performed once an
enemy was staggered cooperative attacks
have been updated in the final preview
bill to allow noctus to trigger them
manually each move can be leveled up the
more you use it increasing its overall
effectiveness in battle and there's
plenty more to unlock for each member in
your party the further along you get the
final preview built also adds in link
strike and blindside link these are
special cooperative attacks that only
occur under specific conditions when
you're near an ally link strike occurs
just after a parry while blindside link
occurs when you're behind an enemy and
those are all the major ways combat has
evolved over the years for more and
everything final fantasy 15
stay tuned to games